[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas trop tôt yo yo yo yo yo
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle partie du match Championnat du
Monde salut Vlad ça le KF salut les
francophonie yo yo il faut profiter de
toi parce que toi tu pars aujourd'hui oh
oui je pars aujourd'hui donc je veux pas
rester pour toutes les parties et
qu'est-ce que je veux dire bah écoutez
j'ai été très déçu comme les autres
supporteurs de Ding de la partie de hier
parce que à vrai dire alors ok je suis
parti après avoir passé deux heures avec
Eve donc je ressens ma place à Fab puis
donc je me suis endormi un petit peu je
me suis réveillé donc et j'ai vu les
positions après tout Rachid
écoute j'ai bien dormi avant j'ai vu au
tour à S8 dans ma suite autour de toi
mais tout de suite quoi après quoi il a
fallu abandonner donc mais dommage
c'était pas le cas alors
les parties commencer le 4 05 je suppose
que malheureusement il y aura
espagnol
ce qui me fait peur toujours parce que
malheureusement dans ce match Ding n'a
jamais réussi d'être trop convaincant
dans ces positions là donc il y aura une
autre petite idée de la part du
cameroscope je sais pas quoi je suis sûr
que c'est toujours à la base de Détroit
au 6e mais il y a tant de tiens
il est pas connu pour jouer
tu te rappelles hier quand on a regardé
les parties de ce fameux leak on a vu
cavalier F6 au troisième et on s'est dit
que ça voulait dire que leak était faux
parce que c'était pas sa prépa c'était
bien ça mais du coup après coup on a
découvert que le lit était vrai pour
plein de raisons en fait il y a des gens
qui ont été vrais et donc ça veut dire
que les pots il a pu sa foi que c'était
ça qu'il avait préparé
ok d'accord ok l'élix pourtant c'est
jamais facile même avec les lits en plus
ok ce que peut aider à l'équipe chinoise
je suppose que ça se peut que les Russes
c'est su avant possible les Russes sont
forts pour ça les Russes sont forts
parce que ce qu'il fait le plus souvent
faut se sent un coefficient jouable et
un autre coup qui vient que peut-être un
peu donc à raconter à nos spectateurs
c'est quand le 7 il est il est il est il
est aussi moche ce coup qu'il est beau
de toi
tu sais j'ai lu une interview de podkin
hier le second nom principal de Yann
[Musique]
et il a dit qu'il pensait de par ce qui
se passe dans le match que Ding avait
bien reçu des conseils de Magnus pour ce
match
je pense que c'est de la parano
de prendre de digne de prendre à porte
comme secondaire principal c'était bien
un conseil de Magnus
base je partage pas son avis je partage
pour son œil dans tous les cas c'est
quoi l'idée de cavaler 7 les deux
principales
écoutez les théories du compo bah
j'adore
sont toujours marrantes mais c'est là il
est bien un peu trop fantaisiste
comme ça gagne le cheval donc non
je pense ce petit roc alors c'est 6 faut
bouger quelque part que les Justiciers
et puis donc
faut analyser mais l'idée intéressante
en fait
ça a été joué d'ailleurs une fois contre
Magnus par par
rapport et il a perdu ok maintenant 200
écoutez c'est l'une de variante les plus
les plus importantes et il y a une
grosse différence entre des cinq avant
ces requier ou après avoir
après avoir se requin c'est quoi la
différence si tu joues 200 tout de suite
ici
maintenant tu peux jouer dans
tu peux après faut se cadre tu peux
jouer tandis que une fois tu te requins
tu peux plus jouer deux dames
parce que sur ça
donc au lieu de dame de 6 à l'heure dame
de oui depuis la théorie Carolet dedans
et puis la théorie
l'ordinateur va montrer un petit
avantage au bois mais c'est pas la peine
de quoi
c'est donc à un autre coup énorme
maintenant
plus ou moins le choix est entre dame 7
ou A5 à 5 pour éviter les B4
puis donc il y a plein de théorie en
fait et puis dame cette le problème
c'est BK
grosse théorie que
moi j'ai appris il y a 5 ans et quelque
chose sans canne peut-être quelques mois
quand on se préparait avec Sacha pour le
tournoi de candidats
bon qu'est-ce que j'ai à dire compliqué
moins bien comme quoi qui sont nul
dans mon
enfant en gros les terroristes c'est
quelque chose comme BK
et puis après l'idée principale de noir
c'est que les buts
etc
mais je veux pas cacher les vérités je
me rappelle pas trop bien de ce qui se
passe ici parce que ça fait 6 ans que
j'ai analysé ça et plus ou moins après
je dois dire que les pauses sont
enseigneuses en fait
c'est pas intéressant de
parmi les positions les plus chiantes
tu dois pas trop croire à l'ordinateur
tu dois réfléchir mais tu veux pas
réfléchir parce que c'est
en tout cas ça réfléchit côté digne et
ce qui il est connu pour jouer cette
ouverture ou pas du tout
parce que ok il est employé à
ma connaissance il est employé
le système Berlan je crois plutôt qu'un
5 fois 6 fois dans sa vie pas plus mais
en général c'est pas son truc en fait et
si vous voulez son choix de virtuel me
pourra pas trop moi j'espérais sur le
français pour faire un break
pour essayer de
gagner avec le noir parce que ici non tu
peux pas gagner tu peux pas
souffrir
ok déjà pas un très bon signe que il est
en train de réfléchir maintenant parce
que cette position là elle était
tellement prévisible donc normalement tu
penses pas sur l'échiquier à 5h mais tu
fais ce que tu as préparé donc si les
réfléchit maintenant je sais pas mais il
peut s'écrouler complètement non à vrai
dire
ok l'huile se porte au niveau de comment
s'appelle de les maîtrise du temps il se
porte bizarrement pendant ce match parce
que bizarre aussi c'est que c'est le
comportement de son équipe parce que tu
habites
tu dis bah écoute mec quoi tu as perdu
autant une fois tu as failli de pierre
de revoir deux demi point tu as perdu
une position nulle et tu as raté une
position gagnante qu'est-ce que c'est
que qu'est-ce que c'est que c'est que tu
réfléchis une fois te préparer ok à 5
comme je dis c'est un autre cours
dame recette
ça stoppe
le 5 je me rappelle pas de la ligne
désolé ça m'arrive aussi moi je sais que
tu recommences
c'est pas au goût de tout le monde
par exemple Peter le code
pour faire des petites nulles
ici ici je sais que
[Musique]
je me rappelle que il y avait une partie
de Hanane avec les bons contre Harmonia
je suppose et donc l'écho a amélioré le
jour de noir et donc il m'a envoyé le
fichier
il a fait une nul voilà propre et sans
bavure drôle
n'est pas du tout d'accord
avec ce scénario alors à 4 c'est pour
pour essayer de jouer bon
psychologiquement c'est un bon choix de
la part de Yann parce que l'autre est en
train de
tomber il faut aider de tomber
définitivement alors
mais objectivement parlant je pense